foreign
members officers members of the public
uh ladies and gentlemen
welcome to this meeting of the
development committee 24th of August
2023 I will now read out the emergency
evacuation announcement
there are no planned fire drills so if
the alarm goes off
please leave the building in an orderly
fashion through the nearest fire exit if
you familiarize your souls with those we
have for the back or the side there the
meeting at the assembly place is for the
on the grass out of the front on the
island out of the front of the building
please do not delay your evacuation to
collect any belongings
please do not return to the building
until given permission to do so by
Council staff
please note that the meeting will be
live streamed
please switch off mobiles or turn them
to silent
please note that toilet and hand washing
facilities are in the foyer area
those observant amongst you will note
that my vice chair is not here tonight
that will come up in the apologies for
absence but I am advised that for me to
have a vice chair for the night that I
need to
ask for a vote and I would like to
propose that Council FD is my vice chair
for the night tonight can I have a
second app please
thank you Mrs councilor Mrs Mason uh all
in favor
thank you very much okay join me please
thank you
okay members of the public are reminded
that this is an official council meeting
and that the applications will debut
debated according to the procedure rules
set out in the council's Constitution
members of the public can you please
note that you are not permitted to speak
at this meeting unless you've registered
to speak with Democratic services
in this way everyone present will be
able to hear the debate and counselors
will be able to make an informed
decision
can I please also remind you to be
respectful of all those attending the
meeting including other members of the
public counselors and officers
members of the public
while you are of course entitled to film
or take photographs during this meeting
can I please emphasize to you that you
should this should be done without
disruption to the meeting and can only
be done from a designated area in the
public seating
can I please therefore ask you to raise
your hand clearly in the air if you wish
to take photographs or film this evening
I don't see any hands so thank you very
much
members your voice will only be captured
on the live stream when your microphone
is switched on so please remember to
switch on your microphone when you are
invited to speak and switch off again
when not speaking
members voting will be done on a show of
hands in line with the Constitution
I will ask for a show of hands for and
then against recommendations and will
also ask for a show of hands for those
wishing to abstain from voting
agenda items one and two apologies for
absence and substitutes we have received
apologies for absence from counselors
Mrs Wilson councilor Mrs Shaw and
councilor Knight
uh councilor Mrs Mason will be
substituting for councilors Mrs Wilson
and councilor Foster substituting for
councilor Mrs Shaw
non-members attending
we have
um counselor across and councilor booth
agenda item four
minutes of the meeting held on the 20th
of July 2023 are the minutes agreements
great thank you
item five
to declare
um
to receive Declarations of interest for
clarity can I just remind members that
we now have three categories of peculiar
interests which are as follows
disclosable peculiar interests DPI other
registerable interest Ori and
non-regitable interest NRI so do I have
any members who need to declare an
interest
do I take it there's a no
okay
thank you members
now before we move on to the uh the
business of tonight I am aware that the
uh the two applications that we will be
discussing tonight are contentious
um when I joined the council in 2016 and
started to get involved with planning
um I was quite surprised at the limiting
um that there was within deciding on
planet planning applications
to make that clear
we as a committee can only refuse a an
application on the grounds of law
or on
planning policy
so with that in mind I'd like to invite
officers to do the uh to um
so sorry I need to actually backtrack
there a little bit we have had
um an addendum
to the uh the applications which has
come out today
have all members seen that and any of
the speakers who are in the uh in the
audience
uh have you all seen that
if if you haven't can you indicate
okay
there are two addendums there was one
that came out today if you haven't seen
it I am minded to adjourn and give you a
copy so as you can actually see it so as
we are being fully transparent
okay so you haven't seen it council Mrs
Mason now I've seen the one that came
out today I haven't seen another one
I've just got a dent of two no one's
giving me addendum one
okay in that case then I am going to
adjourn for 10 minutes and I will give
an opportunity for anyone who needs to
actually see those addendums to actually
read and digest what's in there we'll
come back to you shortly thank you
for clarity I should say that the
addendums have been produced by our
officers in response to comments that
have been received
at the last minute from uh residents and
the idea of this is to actually be
totally clear and transparent in the way
that we are conducting this meeting so
thank you
okay thank you for your patience
everybody uh we'll reconvene the meeting
and we should start off now with uh our
last Katie Fowler to present the
officer's report
thank you Cody
thank you chairman
the site is located on trenders Avenue
the site is formed of a parcel of land
which is edged red here
and measures a site area of some 0.29
hectares
trenders Avenue is a private single
Track Road the site is made up sorry the
site is part way up the road and it's
opposite to the properties here so we
have pine Cottage Mill Cottage the barn
and the properties on heronstring place
the site is to the north of a public
right-of-way footpath which runs along
here sorry my hand streaky the site is
currently occupied by stable block and
is enclosed along part of the Eastern
and Southern boundaries by close board
fence
I'm just going to take members through
some photos of the site
so this is the access point into the
site you can see the gate and then the
closed board fence that goes along the
Southern and Eastern boundaries
foreign
this photo just depicts the public right
away that runs to the south of the site
here you have more of a photo of the
closed board fence against Trends Avenue
[Music]
here you can begin to see the
Residential Properties so you have pine
Cottage with the white render and then
meal Cottage
[Music]
this Market marks the entrance into
heronstream place and you can see the
dwellings there
[Music]
and then again just the pine Cottage and
milk Cottage on trenders Avenue
[Music]
the public right of way foot path again
and this is just to try to show over
into the site there's a better photo
later on but just to demonstrate what
the stable Building looks like to a
degree and obviously you can see the
vegetation that demarcates some of that
eastern boundary on trenders Avenue
[Music]
so this part although the close board
friends looks similar to the application
site this actually demarcates the
boundary of the barns so this is a fork
in the road of trenders Avenue so you
have trenders Avenue still continuing up
here to the north but then also to the
west and you have some soft Landscaping
this is not in the red line boundary of
the application site but does demarcate
between the application site and
treaders Avenue
again this photo just shows that soft
Landscaping so it's not within the red
line site boundary but is demarcating
the site from trenders Avenue
and then a similar photo again
and then this photo just shows a little
bit more into the site so you can see
the stable block building that exists
and then some of what would have been
grazing land at some point
and you can also see just in the
background of the photo the existing
Hedgerow which is within the site
boundary
[Music]
so members may recall that the stable
block which exists in site was tied to a
section 106 agreement
this section 106 agreement stated that
the state block was to be removed at
such a time as the land edged in Blue on
the plan on screen becomes unavailable
for use for the grazing of horses is the
council's understanding that the land
edged in blue is no longer available for
use of the grazing of horses and
therefore the building at prison is
unlawful discussions have taken place
with the planning agent for the scheme
who considers the building to be lawful
the planning agent is of the view that
the building is lawful as the section
106 attempted to govern or restrict the
use of the stable bloating in connection
with the grazing land
therefore the assessments set up set out
within the officers report has
considered the building as being
retained if it were unlawful and as a
change of use if it were lawful
plan admission is sought for the change
of use of land for the stationing of two
pitches for a Roman Egyptian family
each pitch would include one mobile home
and one touring Caravan
so the dark blue rectangles demarcate
the mobile homes here and here and then
these two lighter blue rectangles would
be the touring Caravans this gray
building shows the stable block that
would be retained as a day room and then
you can see the existing vegetation that
goes around the boundaries of the site
to be retained and then here also here
and then along these boundaries and then
there's also some proposed vegetation
within the site too
the application site is located within
the green belt where restrictive
policies apply
the national planning policy for
traveler sites sets out that the travel
that traveler sites in the Greenville
are inappropriate development which is
harmful by definition
in addition The Proposal would have an
impact on the openness of the green belt
in terms of the proposal's contribution
towards the purpose of Greenbelt Land
the development would constitute urban
sprawl and encroachment
The Proposal would therefore be
considered to have a greater impact on
openness and would fail to meet the aims
and purposes of allocating land within
the Greenville
any harm to the green belt is attributed
substantial weight which must be clearly
outweighed by very special circumstances
the very special circumstances of the
application have been set out within the
officer report
these include the existing lack of local
Vision the lack of alternative
accommodation and the personal
circumstances of the applicant
membership be aware that in particular
it should be noted that the best
interest of children are a primary
consideration in this application as the
site would accommodate children under 16
and were permission refused the family
would be forced to live on side of the
road
although not necessarily a determinative
issue no other consideration must be
considered to be more important or given
more weight
the best interest of children must be at
the Forefront of decision makers Minds
when they are exercising all planning
judgments involved in this case
it is considered that there are a number
of matters which are considered to weigh
significantly in favor of the
application and this conclusion would be
consistent with the outcome of recent
appeal decisions
foreign
the officer report has set out that
whether the building is considered to be
lawful on or unlawful the day won't be
acceptable in connection with the pros
use if unlawful there are very special
circumstances which exist that outweigh
the harm to the green belt and if law
lawful then it would be appropriate
development as a change of use is
considered acceptable in the green belt
the cumulative weight of these
considerations are considered to clearly
outweigh the substantial harm to the
green belt
moving on to other considerations
whilst the development would not be
typical for the character of trenders
Avenue The Proposal must not be
discriminated against because the homes
of the ethnic group do not look like
those of the settled communities
conditions have been imposed regarding
the Landscaping on site with the
intention of better integrating the
development within the street scene
further the proposed development would
not be considered to impact upon the
setting of the nearby listed building
a number of comments have been received
regarding the impact on nearby
Residential Properties
it's considered that there would be
sufficient separation with these
properties so that the prose development
would not have an overbearing
overshadowing or overlooking impact that
would be unreasonable
the material considerations pertaining
to the impact on residential Community
have been laid out within the officer
report and found to be acceptable
the proposed development is considered
to provide sufficient access and parking
although there's no specific details of
foul drainage have been submitted a
condition has been recommended requiring
these details
there are a number of trees and hedges
around the perimeter of the application
site however the proposed development
would not be within the root protection
area of any of those trees
finally the application site would not
be considered to exhibit any habitats of
protective species and therefore the
proposal would not have an impact upon
ecology
members will be familiar with the
addendum that was circulated the agenda
made reference to a floor plan of the
day room that has now been provided and
an updated site plan
the addendum recommended that a number
of conditions were updated to reflect
the updated references of those plans it
also recommended the foul drainage
competition be amended to include an
implementation time frame
the application is recommended for
approval chairman subject to the
conditions set out within the officer
report and those mended on the addendum
thank you Katie
the ward members
for this site are
councilors Newport Stanley and Crips
um before I hand over to them we have
three public speakers on this item uh
councilor Alistair Matthews speaking on
behalf of Roth Parish Council councilor
Matthews please take your place at the
microphone
to the side here please you have five
minutes to speak and I'll let you know
when you've got a minute left thank you
Parish Council expressed deep
disappointment with the officer's
recommendations
it appears that lack of conviction in
the past to enact the agreed policy to
accommodate Travelers needs has led to
the various unlawful sites mainly
situated in the Parish of roarth
these have been given the go-ahead by
government inspectors because of frodsha
District's failure to fulfill their
obligations under their policy
this application becomes difficult to
refuse nevertheless we believe all the
objections are still valid and should be
given due consideration
this site is typical of several in the
Rayleigh Park site where permission has
been given an exceptional circumstances
similar to this application
in this case there are several anomalies
although a very late addendum has been
issued to try to address residents
concerns I think it is relevant to
repeat some of the concerns so members
can get a clearer picture of this case
the application is under a previous
landowner's name who confirms he sold
the land two years ago to the Traveler's
family
the last known addressed the family was
in Cranford Park Drive where sporadic
development has taken place over the
years
there is a primary school within a short
distance next to the Robert through
Medical Center and bromford school is
nearby
trend is Avenue in contrast is half a
mile further to Southern Hospital which
was one of the reasons that was quoted
whereas Nicholas is half a mile up an
inadequate narrow road poorly lit with
high Hedges both sides in plate both
sides in places
the only safe way is to drive so
increasing further the existing
congestion on Raw Flame
it is important to refer to the
resident's comments appendix one where
inaccuracies were highlighted
it is admitted that the development
would have an adverse effect on the open
aspect of the green belt in the planning
report
the only justification for approval is
on exceptional circumstances of which
further questions and clarification is
needed
in view of this late clarification and
the initial confusing and accurate
planning application it seems relevant
to quote Bob Neal and the Secretary of
State for communities and local
government when given guidance under the
law
planning permission can be refused on
the grounds of information provided was
insufficient to accurately describe the
nature and anticipated impacts of the
proposed development
over many years this Parish Council has
requested that the district council
should have a policy to cover
development in this unique area of
Rayleigh Park to preserve the character
of housing distribution and wildlife
conservation
what was an open aspect in the green
belt had a stable block erected with the
condition that adequate grazing was
available
this never materialized so an
enforcement order was imposed but like
so many similar violations in the
district was not enforced due to the
serious lack of resources in that
department
whilst we have sympathy to find his
problems it is beholden to this District
to provide another District's displaced
family a safe site adding to the already
inadequate revision to the existing
District's needs provided for in the
development plan
both surface and foul drainage are
existing problems in Rayleigh Park
surface water is drained through
independent plots with various standards
of Maintenance most of which ends up in
regular flooding in watery Lane
through new higher standards no foul
water should enter surface water systems
the environmental agency needs to
Monitor and approve any new applications
prior to approval
any new development should not have an
adverse effect on existing residents
given that there is no right to an
administrative View
this has been addressed by the
resident's written response
it is unfortunate that the perceptional
is given that Travelers are given
special provision in the green belt and
can give rise to Ill filling in the
settled Community where modest
applications are refused on the grounds
of Greenbelt
attempts to communicate with what has
turned out to be the applicant over the
years
when seen on site have been rejected
making integration into the existing
Community difficult to achieve
we ask that this application should be
either deferred or rejected the report
and updates have come at short notice
giving little time to respond adequately
thank you to Mr chairman
Matthews
second speaker is Mr Green who is
speaking on behalf of the applicants
Mr Green please take your place at the
seat and uh
you have five minutes to speak and I as
I have said to the others I will give
you the one minute warning when you've
gotten towards the end thank you
thank you chair good evening good
evening councilors
I'm Nathaniel Green from Green planning
studio and I'm speaking on behalf of our
client
Thomas Scott
this application is here to decide the
matter on planning issues only and this
application is recommended for approval
subject conditions
the application is for a change of use
of land and building for the station of
Caravans for the residential purposes
it is accepted that development in the
metropolitan Greenbelt is inappropriate
but the fact that the council officers
have recommended approval shows that
officers have accepted that there are
very special circumstances to to
overcome this
due to the green belt boundary being
tightly drawn around existing
settlements it is unlikely that you'll
be able to put anything on on anything
other than Greenbelt Land
as your officer report explains in great
detail from paragraphs 2.24 to 2.35 that
is a fundamental need in the district
other than windfall sites such as these
that will not be met in the foreseeable
future
District Council accepts there is a
requirement for at least 10 pitches and
that is likely to be an underestimate
our client and his family are accepted
as having Gypsy status by the council
which is also accepted by the council
that their present living arrangements
involving both doubling up with other
members of the extended family due to
the site that they are on being closed
down by the owner as a result the sites
they are forced to live on are in breach
of their own planning permissions
and as also noted in your report at 2.34
it is not for the applicant to establish
whether there are available sites but
for the council
the council cannot demonstrate a
five-year land supply of deliverable
Gypsy sites and this coupled with the
lack of formal policy regarding windfall
sites such as this one constitutes a
failure of policy that also counts
heavily in favor of the application
this application therefore demonstrates
more than one very special circumstance
that is required to outweigh the harm to
the green belt
allowing this application will allow the
family to have a stable base for their
four children that will allow them to
have an education
it will also allow the applicant's
mother who has health issues to have
access to local Health Facilities
whereas at present she has to travel two
hours for medical care
cyclizing Countryside that is well
screened on three sides by existing
vegetation and the proposed plan shows
that further planting of trees and
hedges will be implemented primarily to
the North and the West
the nearest occupied dwelling is 38
meters away to the east across Trends
Avenue and all structures will be single
story there will be no overlooking
there is considered to be no impact upon
highways and it will also have little
ecological impact upon the immediate
area however an ecological enhancement
condition will be accepted
further to paragraph 2.57 I can confirm
that the indicative four plans have been
supplied to show the conversion of the
stable block into a day room of a
suitable site for two pitches
there have been discussions as to
whether the stable block is lawful or
not as mentioned earlier and whether it
constitutes a new building or a change
of use it has also been suggested that
that the description of the development
be amended to refer to the retention of
the building this suggested change to
the description of the development was
not agreed on the basis that the
building has planning permission the
retention of something is also not an
active development with the only other
option being the material change of use
of the building
the building exists and was erected with
the benefit of planning permission zero
two double zero two three five the 2002
planning permission did not impose any
conditions in relation to the use of the
building or its removal the section 106
agreement sits alongside the planning
permission for the building and it
attempts to govern or restrict the use
of the stable building in connection
with the use of an area of land for the
grazing of horses
should the planning Council Grant the
planning permission for the change of
use of the building which would be use
would be ancillary to the use of the
land for the stationing of Caravans for
residential purposes then the section
106 agreement would cease to have a
minute left or practical or meaningful
effect as the building would have a new
permitted purpose
the recommendation comes with 11
conditions and even allowing for the
amended conditions how our client is
happy to comply with them
and on this basis I urge you to apply to
approve this application thank you
thank you Mr Green please return your
seat a third speaker is Mr dagg who is
speaking on behalf of the residents
objecting to the application Mr Dad
please take your face of the microphone
you have five minutes thank you
thank you very much thank you fellow
chairman members I'm John dagg I'm
instructed by Mrs Paula Fisher and
representing residents in Heron
streamplace and trenders Avenue you've
got a full report I obviously can't go
through all of the details now what I
seek to do is to draw members attention
to particular points which would ask you
to consider in balancing the planning
considerations in the case
Gypsy and traveler applications as you
well know present particular issues and
that's why government has issued a
separate policy document planning policy
The Traveler sites as referred to uh in
the officer report
can I just refer you to the government's
overarching aim paragraph three of that
document to ensure fair and equal
treatment for travelers in a way that
facilitates the traditional and nomadic
way of life of Travelers while
respecting the interests of the settled
community and then there are a number of
points set out in the aims and I can
just refer you to some of those
to increase the number of traveler sites
in appropriate locations with planning
permission
to reduce tensions between settled and
traveler communities and also for local
planning authorities to have due regard
to the protection of local amenity and
the local environment
when you look at this policy document
it's important to bear in mind it stands
alongside the nppf as an important
consideration and of course alongside
your own development plan you have to
consider of course the development plan
and all of the other material
considerations your development plan has
got policy in it of course and was
active traveler sites and also of course
it has policy in it with regard to
design and amenity and I'll come to that
later
it's not disputed that there's a
deficiency of provision in this District
you all know what the difficulties are
I'm not going to dispute what the
officer had to say about that the sites
in the green belt it's acknowledged by
the officer in the report that harm to
both the openness and the appearance of
the green belt will arise that's the
starting point the recommendation to
Grant planning permission is based on
the conclusion that there were very
special circumstances and and it's a
very important and there is compliance
with all other material considerations
as we'll be seeing from the report this
conclusion is the outcome of a balancing
exercise I submit that some important
considerations have not been given
sufficient weight and that the balance
can reasonably be tipped against the
grant of permission I also comment on
the evidence which has been
confidentially provided going to the
applicant's claimed Gypsy status and his
family's circumstances I deal now with
context as you all know every site is
different and every case should be
considered a Monitor and individual
Merit
while this site is in of course in the
green belt it's also very close to
existing housing there's a significant
settled Community adjacent
there were 13 residents in the vicinity
eight of whom are in the immediate
vicinity and of course there are also
houses strung along trenders Avenue to
the south of this site
and if if you have any doubt about this
um please do resolve in due course to
have a site inspection uh before you
finally determine the matter
[Music]
to the immediate east of this site is an
area which was called cell's yard it was
redeveloped more than 10 years ago
it's now uh Huron stream place and
trenders Muse there are six houses there
they are very close to this proposed
Gypsy and traveler site
the entrance uh to uh The Traveler site
is immediately opposite of the the gate
um to harrenstream place and also to the
immediate east of the site of the
long-standing mill Cottage and pine
Cottage while to the north of the barn
Lakeside Barnum trendless hall now the
officers one minute left already dealt
uh with that
can I just suggest that this proposal
would be in conflict with policy D1 of
your own development plan if you have a
look at your own development plan it
goes to ensure that new development
should respect and make a positive
contribution towards the built
environment look at your own policy DM
long design of new developments
particularly at points nine and eleven
with regard to scale and form
appropriate to the locality
um just a word about evidence I've
suggest that some of the evidence that's
been put forward here has been rather
unsatisfactory my clients haven't had
the opportunity to consider it it only
appeared when it was in the officer
report what has emerged which is of a
great interest in the second addendum is
that the family here the Scott family do
it at the moment have somewhere where
they can live there is no immediate
pressure on that family
I would submit that it would be
reasonable to refuse planning permission
on the basis of inappropriateness of the
development in relation to Housing close
by the unsatisfactory access for Caravan
traffic and the impact on local
character and amenity thank you chairman
I'm sorry over around very slightly
thank you very much okay thank you Mr
Veg if you'd like to return to your seat
foreign
members
and Ward members are there any visiting
members wishing to speak nope thank you
uh Ward Members First
councilor Stanley do you wish to speak
as Ward member
you have the opportunity to as wall
members speak first
microphone please
microphone please sorry can I speak to
the officers report and then at the end
uh categorize what I wanted to say yeah
if I just make it clear to everybody I
will give everyone five minutes but in
the interest of giving every councilor
the opportunity to speak you'll have the
five minutes and you'll then you'll have
a rights reply so if we can just bear
that in mind that would be great yeah is
that five minutes in relation to what
the officers have said
yes oh right okay
I wanted to come back at the end but um
you will have a right to reply everybody
yeah oh thank you
um could I ask the officers if um
the flooding area
um would that
um
is that controlled in any any shape or
form as to how far that flooded area
would come also would it be possible to
include wall councilors for the hedges
and fencing that's going to be erected
and
would it not be practical for the EA to
on the foul drainage on page three of
the momentum would it be not possible
for the EA to give the approval of the
failed drainage and not the local
Authority as we do not understand fail
drainage in our
Council
can we also
I don't see any details of rain water
collections from the buildings
and also could we have a time limit put
in the to the uh
to these
um
according to the foul drainage and also
to the rain water as a time limit or if
the or how long will it take them to put
that in place
one little thing I want you to ask is
the size of the dining room as the
building has not been uh can I say
legitimized in the way of enforcement
is the size of that building
smaller or larger than the two day rooms
that would have to go on that site thank
you
thank you councilor standy I have
no German
um I I haven't got anything to say about
that what it is it I've read all the
documents thoroughly and I've listened
to what the officers and the various
people have said this is a very complex
in my opinion very complex and involved
case and into understand this I'm not
totally unfamiliar with this area I'm
not a local councilor there totally
unfamiliar and for me to understand all
of this in its proper form and to
understand what's being said I'd like to
put forward the motion that we defer
this to a site visit before we can come
to any conclusion
award I think
those in favor sorry
does anyone want to speak to the motion
okay in that case I'll take it straight
to a vote those in favor of deferral to
a for a site visit
okay
okay thank you those against
any abstain
thank you that motion is carried so this
application is deferred
for a site visit by the committee
thank you
all right so we now move on to agenda
item seven
uh land West Side Junction of Magnolia
Road and Lincoln Road Rochford
members again there's additional
information relating to this application
set out in the addendum
uh which obviously everyone has had a
chance this evening to uh View
again I'm going to ask Katie Fowler to
present the officer's report thank you
before we do that Mr chairman point of
order if we have deferred the other one
and this is a very very similar
application I may I suggest with this
one is deferred as well for a site visit
can I propose that before we have this
to save the committee's time
can I just take advice on that minute
yes
okay then so councilor Constable you are
recommending deferral this
for for a site visit as per the other
application as they are very very
similar in context and it would be
beneficial if we had a site visit and
I'm just trying to save the uh
everyone's time tonight and not go
through all the other stuff for it okay
so do we have a second there
councilor Myers
anyone want to speak to it
counselor Mrs Mason
thank you chair I will speak to the
jifferent and having read the report and
knowing the area well
I am pleased to support the move for
deferral for a site visit it's a very
awkward access it's a very difficult
situation and there is a lot of concern
about this application and I do think we
need to look at it very carefully and
with the fullest knowledge that we can
in the site visit will afford US that
information thank you
look I'm just being advised that it
would probably be quite useful if we had
the full presentation so as we
understand what actually the application
is in its fullest so as when we do have
the site visit then there may be things
that we could then be alerted to that we
might need to actually
um be mindful of so with your agreement
I will ask Katie to do the presentation
for us please thank you Mr chairman I
think that's an excellent idea yeah
we'll come back to the motion
after the presentation thank you thank
you chairman the application site is
located on the corner of Magnolia Road
and Lincoln Road
so you can see the site as outlined in
red
and then this road that runs up to the
east of the site is Lincoln Road and
then this one is
Magnolia Road
the site is formed of an area of land
that measures some 0.8 hectares Magnolia
Road and Lincoln Road are private roads
the sites are joined to the north by
Doric Lodge which you can see here
to the West is Wayside Lodge here
and then opposite the site on the East
is the Glen or shall in the friendly
category
the site is largely unoccupied with the
exception of a couple of dilapidated
buildings which you'll see from my
photos in a second
so this was taken from the site access
you can see obviously it's mostly
grazing land and then there's the two
for horses in the background of the
photo
and this just shows part of one of the
dilapidated buildings I'll zoom in on
the next photo then you can see
so you have the remains of what probably
once was a stable building but obviously
can't be used for that anymore and then
a building of some sort there also
and then a similar photo as well
[Music]
so you can see the application site here
you can see the bounds of trees
surrounding the site also through the
middle of it and then grazing land
around that
so this looks onto the southern boundary
that runs parallel to Magnolia Road
[Music]
and this also looks onto the southern
boundary parallel to Magnolia Road
here you can see the site access with
the gate and existing boundary
treatments
and then again from Lincoln Road looking
onto the site axis
you can also start to see up Lincoln
Road at this point and either side it
being encompassed by hedgerows and trees
and then a similar photo of the access
point
this is looking up Lincoln Road towards
Doric Lodge
this photo is looking back towards
Magnolia Road in the background but
still on Lincoln Road
and then finally this photo is looking
Westward or Magnolia road with the
application site on the right hand side
and then on the left hand side behind
that Hedgerow is the railway line
[Music]
planning permission is sought for the
change of use of land for the stationing
of two pitches for two Romani Gypsy
families each pitch would include one
mobile home one touring Caravan and one
day room so just for clarification the
mobile homes would be the dark blue
rectangles the day rooms the pink
rectangles and then the light blue blue
rectangles the touring Caravans
the application site is located within
the green belt where restrictive
policies apply the national planning
policy for traveler sites sets out that
traveler sites in the green belt are
inappropriate development which is
harmful by definition
in addition The Proposal would have an
impact on the openness of the green belt
and in terms of the proposal's
contribution towards the purposes of
Greenbelt Land the development would
constitute Urban Sport and encroachment
The Proposal would therefore be
considered to have a greater impact on
openness and would fail to meet their
aims and purposes of allocating now
within the green belt any harm to the
green belt is attributed substantial
weight which must be clearly outweighed
by very special circumstances
the very special circumstances of the
application have been set out with
enough to report these include the
existing lack of low copper Vision the
lack of alternative accommodation and
the personal circumstance of the
applicant members should be aware that
in particular the best interest of
children are a primary consideration in
this application as a site would
accommodate children under 16 and where
permission refused the families would be
forced to live on the side of the road
although not necessarily a determinative
issue no other consideration must be
considered to be more important or given
more weight
the best interests of children must be
at the Forefront of decision makers
Minds when they're exercising all
planning judgments involved in this case
it's considered that there are a number
of matters which are considered to weigh
significantly in favor of the
application and this conclusion would be
consistent with the outcome of the
recent appeal decisions
the cumulative way of these other
considerations are considered to clearly
outweigh the substantial harm in the
Greenville
whilst the development would not be
typical for the character of Magnolia
Road all income Road The Proposal must
not be discriminated against because the
homes of this ethnic group do not look
like those of the settled communities
conditions have been imposed regarding
the Landscaping on site with the
attention of better integrating the
development within the Street Scene It
is considered that there would be
sufficient separation with the with the
properties nearby to the development so
the appraisal would not have an
overbearing overshadowing or overlooking
impact that would be unreasonable
the material considerations pertaining
to the impact on residential amenity
have been laid out within the officer
report and found to be acceptable
[Applause]
the proposed development is considered
to provide sufficient access and parking
although no specific details of the foul
drainage have been submitted the
condition has been recommended requiring
requiring these details
is highlighted that the site is within
an area at risk of surface water
flooding as such a condition has been
recommended to be imposed requiring a
surface water draining scheme to be
agreed with the local planning Authority
there are a number of trees in hedgerows
around the perimeter of the application
site
some of the proposed hard standing would
likely be within the root protection
area of a number of these trees as such
a condition has been recommended
requiring an agricultural impact
assessment be submitted
an ecological appraisal was submitted
with the application which highlighted
that the site encompassed potential
habitats for a number of protected and
priority species subject to the
implementation of the recommended
mitigation and safeguarding measures
outlined in this appraisal it is
considered that no significant harm to
any habitats or formal species of
Interest would occur
members will be familiar with the
addendum that was circulated and the
this recommended that a number of
conditions were updated to reflect the
updated reference of the amended site
plan it also included the foul drainage
condition be amended to include an
implementation time frame the
application is recommended for approval
chairman subject to the conditions set
up within the officer report and those
amended on the addendum thank you
thank you Katie now
um I've been having discussions while
you've been presenting I do apologize
for that but I think in order to be fair
and to give
a similar kind of opportunity for
members to understand what they're going
to be looking at at this site that I
should allow the public speakers to
present
um so in that case
um we have three speakers
and the first is councilor Weir speaking
on behalf of Hawk Hall Parish counselor
Council councilor Weir if you'd like to
come to the microphone and you'll have
five minutes to speak
um and I will let you know when you have
a minute left thank you
[Music]
good evening everybody
are representing Hopewell Parish Council
[Music]
it
to consider the mixed use of keeping up
a horse and stabbing of Caravans
in their life the lion of Hearts
standard
they see now actually we've talked
talked about two Caravans and now oh
now they're talking about two Caravans
two deaths they sent us and two
counselor would it help
um if you have your submission written
yes would it help if someone reads it
for you no it's all right okay
this artist within the green belts
and the council has previously refused
the use of this because of its Green
Belt status when the land was altered in
the virtual District Council
stated that no planet in her Mission
could be
permitted
and don't feel there's any changes to
Warrant this
um be regarding any of the development
policy traveler's site
in the green belt appropriate
development
is harmful to the green belt and should
not be approved accepting very special
circumstances this has not been
demonstrated
Hawthorne Parish Council and
many of the hundred trust residents who
have
registered objection to this application
it sets a president for
a similar
applications in the Greenbelt owners of
green belt and
who live nearby area code
sell their land for more Gibson Gypsy
sites
once the land is occupied
planning enforcement to prevent any
expansion is difficult
the applicant
has
provided no response to the question and
there is no no freezer or Hedges on the
land adjacent to the proposed
development site
Hopewell Parish Council man this is the
site
Magnolia roads adjacent to this
that
development
and
we are worried that um
how
Nature Reserve can actually be
come under pressure from existing
and
any people
using it
um
with
[Applause]
[Music]
the local local plan is due in 2023 it's
likely to include Michelin Farm sites as
a preferred option for Egyptian traveler
site
the lack of authority
yeah their main parts of it led to the
granting of some planning appeals or or
Travelers sites what is actually needed
is one
site which can be controlled
not little
a couple here and a couple there there
should be a prophesied
laughs
that return as before I did no response
to the question is the site at risk of
flooding
the parish council is aware that the
application site floods
severely in the winter months
and the service water runs for Messenger
Heights down to Lincoln Road and Durham
Road which has no drainage
of on Magnolia Road the site is
dead water at times and although the
application forms reference to the
government flood map which says
the flows
from this recipe counter Council they
flood Authority for the area
and it snaps it says societies
categorized as a high risk
or flooded
[Music]
foreign
forces which is one of the
primary uses of the land
listed on the application site
or Forest Council would ask but Rochford
District Council to
explore why this matter has not been
admitted
to the application
I have let your time run on if I can
just give you notice I'll give you
another minute okay thank you
are you finished
yeah yeah okay thank you okay so we're
if you'd like to return to your speech
the second speaker is Mr Green again who
is speaking on behalf of the applicants
Mr Green please take your place at the
microphone and you have five minutes
again I will give you one minute notice
if we get to the end
okay
foreign
thank you chair thank you councilors uh
yes you probably remember who I am
and I have to say a lot of what I'm
going to say is going to sound very
similar because most of the principles
involved are very similar in both sites
but obviously there are certain
practical aspects on of each site that
are different nonetheless I still need
to go through this so that you get the
you know our as the agent the full
the full sort of um
thrust of our arguments again
once again I must remind you that this
must be decided on planning issues only
and it is recommended for approval
subject conditions
and the application is for the Mixed use
of the keeping forces and stationing of
Caravans for residential use and laying
of hard standing in the erection of day
room ancillary to that use in effect two
Gypsy pitches
it is accepted the development in the
metropolitan green belt is inappropriate
but the fact the officers Council
Council officers have recommended
approval show that the officers have
accepted that there are very special
circumstances to overcome this
again similar situation is the green
belt boundaries are drawn extremely
tightly and so it is unlikely you will
find any other land other than green
belt
Azure officers report again explains in
paragraphs in this case paragraph
217-24 there is a fundamental need in
the district other than windfall sites
such as these that will not be met in
the foreseeable future
um and again there is at least there's a
requirement for at least 10 pitches and
again that is likely to be underestimate
our clients and his family our
acceptance having Gypsy status by the
council it has accepted the council that
their present living arrangements again
also involve doubling up with other
family members
and again I must remind you that it is
not the applicant to establish whether
there are available sites for the
council
also must remind you that the council
cannot demonstrate five year land Supply
and that the former lack of policy
constitutes the failure policy and that
acts in favor of the application
and therefore the application therefore
demonstrates more than one very special
circumstances required to outweigh the
harm to the green belt
two families involved
um the Connors this will allow the
corners to have a stable base for their
eight children that will allow them to
have an education that at present they
do not have access to
in particular one child would then be
able to access a special needs school
that at present the child is unable to
do so you're lacking a formal address
the same child also has a health issue
that a stable base will assist clearly I
can't go into details on these
Gaskins children or are already in a
local school and this will ensure that
they continue to receive their education
again one child has a learning
difficulty and this proximity to the
child's existing School assistance
education
you'll also note from your report that
two members of the family have mental
health issues that a settled environment
will assist
and another child has a medical issue
that is treated in London and the site's
proximity to London will help in that
regard
the site lies in Countryside that is
well screened onto Side by dense
vegetation
the developed areas on the Eastern side
of the site where it is surrounded by
scrub the proposed plan shows that
further planting of trees and hanches
will be implemented primarily along the
entranceway although further planting
can be conditioned
the nearest occupied dwelling is 28
meters away to the north and as all
structures will be single story there
will be no overlooking and there is
considered by officers to be no impact
upon highways
a comprehensive ecological survey was
undertaken this year and it confirms
that no statutory or non-statury
designations are present within the site
it recommended some ecological
enhancements to be implemented and these
are in the conditions
the site is close to Bridal waves and as
the application is also for keeping
forces this will have significant safety
and Welfare benefits of the keeping
forces off the road Network
thank you issues have been raised
regarding flooding
um you remote from the plan that the
whole of the hard standing is permeable
and in fact permeable hard standing is
of Greater permeability than existing
vegetation so you'll find that you are
actually increasing the permeability of
the site in retro in retrospect to
um surface water
the recommendation comes with 19
conditions and our client is happy to
comply with them and I on that again on
this basis I urge you to approve the
application thank you
thank you Mr Green
if you'd like to return to your seat and
we have a third speaker that is Mrs
Spillane who is objected to the
application
Miss Spillane please take your place at
the microphone and as you'll know by now
you have five minutes and I will let you
know when you have a minute left thank
you
evening evening councilors I'm Kelly
Spillane and I live in direct Lodge
which is next to the application site
direct Lodge is in a court appointed
trust for my son Kai who has cerebral
palsy it was purchased in September 21
with the sole intention of providing Kai
with a quiet and tranquil place to live
life to his full potential
when searching for the property the
application was a crucial Factor as Kai
is extremely self-conscious and suffers
with debilitating anxiety because of
this
so by choosing within the green Bill and
so close to the Nature Reserve I have
the deputies are considered there to be
amenable to non-existent risk of further
surrounding development
after living here for two years Kai has
progressed from never leaving the house
to regularly walking his dog and
volunteering at the local charity shop
the potential increase of residents over
50 in Lincoln Road and over 60 in
Magnolia road is already having a
detrimental impact on Kaya direct Lodge
was supposed to be a place that Kai
could eventually feel safe and
comfortable for the rest of his life due
to Kai's disabilities he is particularly
sensitive to change in his surroundings
excess noise and visual stimulus these
factors can lead cry to become
distressed and highly anxious which in
turn causes him weight loss panic
attacks and withdrawal the court
appointed deputies along with myself are
therefore very concerned about the
implications of this development
requires well-being as a result the
deputies instructive planning
Consultants to issue a letter of
objection the objection letter set out a
number of grounds of objection I'm not
planning an or expert and I don't intend
to address the Council on a majority of
points set out instead I'm using my time
to explain the impact of the pro the
proposed development on my son
I appreciate the application has
attracted a large amount of public
interest so if cancer is understandably
not had the time to read the letter of
objection I have copies with me which
I'm more than happy to hand out
the one legal point that I've been
advised to make clear is giving Kai's
disabilities the council are under a
legal duty to consider Kai's personal
circumstances to satisfy themselves at
the proposal will not adversely impact
him the legal basis for this obligation
is set out in the Egyptian letter
submitted by the planning consultant and
as I understand it comes from the
equality Act 2010. what I find highly
concerning and disappointing is that the
case officer's report at the very end of
paragraph 4 states that an assessment
under the equality act 2010 has taken
place which advises there would be no
impact arising from the proposed
development I'm not sure how such an
assessment was conducted as no one from
the council has been to see me nor has
the assessment carried out by the
council been made public
the council were fully aware of Kai's
disability disabilities as it was
clearly set out in the objection letter
I really therefore do not understand how
Council will reached such a conclusion
and I'd be very grateful if counselors
you could pick this point up with the
case officer prior to voting to
understand what steps were taken in the
assessment in any event I completely
disagree that the proposed development
will not impact Kaya as well as giving
rise to a built form on the neighboring
land that has potential to overlook into
direct Lodge I note from the case
officers report that the site is a to
act as a base for at least 16 residents
with 12 of these being occupants being
up children under the age of 16.
the noise and disturbance that is likely
to emanate from the application site at
all hours of the day will be extreme
especially if the children living on the
applications like their friends over or
decide to play on the farm Vehicles
which will undoubtedly be purchased to
assist with the upkeep of the equestrian
site
the result of this will mean that Kai
will be unable to enjoy the current
peaceful amenity land in and around
direct Lodge which will only serve to
excavate his health conditions Kai has
an extremely has had an extremely
difficult life his disabilities arise
from a medical error at Birth and it's
been a very uphill struggle from him
since his time to develop any sense of
self-confidence however since moving to
Derek Lodge he has vastly improved the
quiet surroundings have allowed Kai to
come out with shell and his panic
attacks that were very frequent have
steadily started to reduce
as a mother I am simply distraught that
all of this progress is likely to be
lost if this development takes place I'm
also here as a representative of the
neighbors who are united in our new
terms
about the proposed planning application
we believe it has the potential to
impact our quality of life and the
character of our neighborhood in
significant ways stated in over 130
comments received in objection to this
planning application
it is heartening to know that there are
alternative options available within the
designated traveler sites that are
available to rent or buy via a quick
Google search
that align with the criteria set out by
the applicant rather than encroaching on
our precious Green Space this
alternative also upholds the culture and
historical significance of our
communities
I'm very grateful for the Council of
taking the time to listen to my position
on behalf of Kai myself and the
surrounding neighbors for the reason sit
out above along with those set out in
the objection letter we request that
this application be refused
thank you thank you Mr Malone if you'd
like to return to your seat and I'd like
to add my personal thanks to all the
speakers tonight I'm sure you are
disappointed that you're not going to
get a
um decision tonight but obviously the
decision will be coming in future
now I'm aware that members want to speak
but we do have a motion on the table
um so counselor Constable if you'd like
to
just reiterate your motion
that the motion be deferred to allow for
a site visit by members
okay thank you and I believe councilor
Mars you're seconding it okay so those
in favor of the motion please may I
speak to the defense sorry can we speak
today do you apologize yes you need to I
need to give time for you to speak to
the motion
I've got several points to make but I
just make one particular one which is
very relevant which is I do believe that
the approach roads Magnolia and Lincoln
Road totally inadequate for construction
and Caravan traffic and yeah absolutely
support the motion
can I just emphasize that we are just
speaking to the motion and these are
things that we can discuss when it comes
back to the the committee sorry
counselor award
yeah thank you chairman I would like to
have a written deposition from
councilman we're aware because I
couldn't understand unfortunately a lot
of what she had to say and I think uh I
get the gist that a lot of it is very
important and we should take note of it
so if we can have a written accurate
deposition from her I would really
appreciate that thank you I had actually
got that in mind to have a word with a
counselor we are afterwards so I'll have
a word with you after if that's okay
confirmation Mrs Mason sorry
thank you I know we're deferring this
for a site visit but before we do that
I'd like some clarity the the
I can understand the plan roughly the
stylized plan that the officers have put
up there but it Bears no relation
to the plan
that we have in front of us I can see
there's a legend on there
um could the officers
we obviously can't read that Legend from
here I'm assuming it's a Legend
um regarding the various colors Etc
you've explained that the proposed
buildings
but the site itself is triangular the
part
name yellow is not so would you like to
explain why
those different colors are there and the
significance and perhaps The Legend on
there might help
and the white liners were around it yeah
that that's the plan we have which as
you see I know the site and I can
visualize what's going on but the
members that don't know the site that's
quite confusing yeah so this is the
obviously the red line site so it's
triangular in shape and you have the
access towards the bottom of the
junction with Lincoln Road and Magnolia
road so if I go to the layout plan and
this is on public access as well so you
can see some of the Triangular shapes
you have the access that would be
retained at the bottom of the page and
then the Triangular shape begins and
then it comes down obviously on the red
line plan it does carry on
and then it comes back down to meet so
there is a small part of the site that
has been cut out of the plan but that is
just for the grazing of the horses there
is another plan if I am
just find that one
foreign
[Music]
so hopefully that demonstrates where the
grazing land would be so that's why it's
just cut out of that is just so that you
can see the detail of the site layout so
if I just go through that
so the orange color is the hard standing
or the purple permeable Paving
the two dark blue rectangles are the
mobile homes the two pink rectangles of
the day rooms the two lightly rectangles
are the touring Caravans
if I zoom in a little bit further you
might be able to distinguish the um
the lines of the on-site so you can
hopefully see that these ones are dashed
with a line whereas these ones here are
circular with a line so the ones which
are circular with a line are Paddock
style fencing whereas the ones that are
dashed with the line are a closed board
friends which would separate the two
sides you then have in between the
mobile home and the day rooms these
orange dashing which marks the foul
drainage
foreign
just go down
further you can see
here marks a soak away and then this is
slightly dashed so if I zoom in that
might be a bit clearer to see
but you can see that so that is proposed
vegetation this is also for post trees
and hedges
[Music]
and you have a proposed gate here
and then I go down to the access and you
can see that there is a post and rail
fence and a gate and then this is tarmac
if I just go up to the top of the site
[Music]
so you can see the site boundaries
you can see that there is
dashing here to show Paddock fencing
which exists at the moment
and then
again so this is the edge of the plan
but you can see Paddock fencing here and
then along that breaks up some of the
grazing area so that exists at the
moment as well
I think some of it is a little bit
dilapidated but that for the most part
they there is there and I think that's
most the points that are covered on the
veg on the
um Legend thank you
okay Mrs Mason are you okay with it
yes no no I
I could see it I could locate it but
where the people
's triangular was it shown in its
entirety yeah we're having difficulty
um understanding the positioning on the
site so I think it would be helpful to
have that information before we have a
site visit yeah okay I think that
explanation was very helpful thank you
thank you
yeah thank you chairman um I've been
looking at uh satellite uh images of the
site
uh the triangle I found the triangle
exactly where it is
um there is a blue
a blue line I take it that's a Waterway
is it
what's what's the blue down there
because on on this satellite image it
shows trees or hedging right down that
middle
so I need to understand
um what is the quality of those trees
and heading are they trees are they
hedging what are they because I can see
where the shape of the yellow bit the
hard standing will go which will fit
into a little triangle when you look at
the satellite picture you could actually
impose it on there I just need to
understand that sorry if I could
interrupt there I think this will be
cleared when we come to go to the site
so I think that's that's something we
can actually clarify then if that's okay
anyone else wants to speak to the motion
yeah
okay right so we have a motion for
deferral pending a site visit
um can I have an indication of those in
favor please
that is unanimous so that item is
deferred
and therefore at German if I might just
before you close the meeting
obviously the trinders Avenue isn't not
fit for this many cars that are going to
be arriving there so there needs to be
some sort of um where you're going to
park
as you won't be able to park in trindus
Avenue yeah I think this will be
clarified on the site visit so there are
uh things that are aware you have to be
outside of the treaty if you put cars
that's what I'm saying yeah well I'm I'm
sure that we can take that on board and
we'll we'll be uh considering that on
the site visit uh I have one more item
before we close police items referred
from the weekly list there are none
therefore at
um seven minutes to nine I declare this
meeting closed thank you everyone for
attendance
good night